when we first started measuring ice back
in the early 1990s nobody knew
basically what Greenland was doing was
that getting bigger or getting smaller
that was a total unknown and so in 2000
we published our first results of using
an older version of the technology that
we're using now and ice bridge and what
that showed us was that the ice sheet
was not in balance it was delivering ice
into the oceans and raising sea level
even at that time and that process has
accelerated
it's retreated kilometers since that
time I think it's fair to say an
alarming rate they're like bathtubs full
of water essentially and so if you take
the plug out then then it's gonna go
into the ocean and sea level will rise
[Music]
maturity are the people of North
American lives on the shoreline you
would European continent the same South
America the same that means maturity
where people live would be afflicted by
the change if we are true believers in
spirit
we cannot just watch them drown
[Music]
whoo I give up
I surrender we are at the terminus of
Russell glacier of the Greenland ice
sheet and so what we're standing in
front of right here is where essentially
the glacier comes to an end so you can
see it's melting you can hear it
actually and you can see the icicles
hanging from the front of the cliff
which indicates that the melt has
started and you can hear the ice kind of
cracking and popping which means that
it's actively breaking off and falling
it's a dynamic landscape as you can see
things are falling you can hear the
liquid water I mean this is just a
changing evolving landscape and you can
visibly see that it's like if I don't
want to leave I want to stay here it's
it's just beyond words
I went to a very small liberal arts
school in Vermont and I think I applied
to like 15 different grad schools so I
had no idea what I wanted to do and I
ended up in from Vermont all the way to
Oregon and I'd never seen a glacier
before until I went to Oregon
[Music]
and I just was I fell in love I
absolutely fell in love and I don't even
know if I can necessarily say what it
was about them but the landscape was so
different and dramatic to me it's a very
moving landscape and it truly touched me
as it pretty much directed my career
choice in life so yeah it was love at
first sight I guess
[Music]
if you're coming to a place like this
you have to be a person that gets along
with other people and is super friendly
and outgoing because if you come here
and you're not like that then you're
probably going to be miserable and never
come back again
[Music]
I've eaten more meals with some of the
folks here and that I'm in the field
with that I have with other most
important people in my life back home we
spend 16 hours a day together most days
you can't spend that kind of time with
each other or not basically become a
family we're a long ways from our
families were a long ways from our
logistical trains we're a long ways from
most things and so we have to depend on
each other and ultimately for me that
becomes probably the most rewarding part
of this whole job is getting to work
with such a great team so good so good I
love it well here we are
[Music]
welcome to Greenland
[Music]
[Music]
some snacks for the plane
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because of the
[Music]
and of course it's all mine
having the chance to actually see the
ice it connects you to it it's sort of
an inspirational thing from a scientific
standpoint to be able to look at
something that you've been you know
building your career off of and looking
at how beautiful it is
and you lose that inspiration when
you're just working at a computer all
day
right there 25 miles copy Thanks hey
Aaron any plan to go back to the dump to
pick up that bench I could use me bad
yeah you can't blame me at the brakes
job a person IceBridge is a NASA program
meant to fill in knowledge about the
Earth's cryosphere the Earth's ice cover
the idea is we're trying to measure
everything about the ice from the top of
the ice all the way down to where it
meets the bedrock and why would we want
to do that well the top of the ice is
about taking a snapshot of what the
state of the Earth's ice cover is now
and how that compares to how it was in
prior years but in order to understand
those changes we have to put them in
context most people would be very
disappointed if they were plopped in the
middle of an ice well for many reasons
they would be disappointed but if you're
parked in the middle of an ice sheet
it's flat and white and boring and it's
just covered in snow but the interesting
part is when you have a radar that you
can actually see internal horizons
underneath the surface and you can use
those internal horizons to actually look
back through time so it's sort of like
tree rings basically the ice sheet is
its own time capsule you can go back in
time and understand how it's changing if
you get more snowfall than ice mass loss
then the ice sheet is growing but if you
get less snowfall thin ice mass loss
then it's shrinking and so it's a key
ingredient in understanding the glaciers
contribution to sea-level rise
[Music]
[Music]
genuinely I'm like a little kid out here
I get to play around with computers and
lasers and airplanes and weather you
know we fly this airplane at 1,500 feet
above the surface so there are many many
many times or we are down in a glacier
valley collecting detailed measurements
of that glacier and the walls of the
canyon are way above us on both sides of
the airplane it is spectacular to be
flying that way every day that's the
view from our office window that hardly
anybody ever gets to see and anybody
anywhere in the world regardless of
their nationality can access our data as
long as they have an internet connection
my hope is that that open data policy
leads to a better world but knowledge of
the Earth's cryosphere is frankly in its
infancy right now in my opinion and we
have a long way to go to to really
understand what's going on up here okay
let's do you breathe
starting with ATM hey I had a great day
today
weather cooperated for data volumes g5
collected 31 gigabytes d6 collected 162
gigabytes 52
[Music]
I'm lucky today I don't know how people
would study ice in the 50s what did you
go to the ice and you know make a
measurement dig a hole and then come
back and and I mean how you're supposed
to make an inference about the entire
ice sheet just from that one data point
mainly people thought that these ice
sheets responded on such long timescales
that they would never be able to change
anything to actually impact ice sheets
enough that would cause a visible change
over human timescales
with the advent of satellites and they
opened a lot of people's eyes to whoa
these actually are changing on
timescales that we can understand and so
that was a big difference because for a
while it was like oh I study an ice
sheet and it changes over a thousand
years but now it's like whoa these can
actually have dramatic changes right now
and we can see them and it can impact
basically everyone
thirty people dead in one apartment
complex alone hundreds of houses trashed
at the ocean flash gone through him
hurricane Harvey slammed ashore Friday
night as a category fool do not come
back to the evacuation zones it has just
begun and it's going to get worse it's
hard to get people excited about ice
sheets when you tell them oh they're
contributing a millimeter per year to
sea level and and it it's a hard number
to tell people so you know you think
this much you know how is that going to
matter but it's the impact of storms
that gets magnified once you have an
additional millimeter that can then
impact a much larger area if you have a
massive storm we're pushing the extreme
so we're getting more extreme storms and
then if we have resin seas to go along
with it that means the impact is just
gonna be more widespread
[Music]
rising sea level is going to displace a
lot of people and typically it it's a
lot of the people who financially don't
have the means to necessarily to move
from where they've grown up their entire
lives
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the month of June in 1975 is my
mother and father instructed me that I
should tell the world that this big ice
is melting we knew that it was nothing
because here on this the water was
coming out in 1963 in the month of
January now you can see it's nothing
from being 1,500 meters and I spoke
about that at United Nations in the
Archos of 1978 that was the first time
it was borne out by the native people
that the ice is melting I began to be
invited by organizations and events and
ended up traveling for United Nations
all over the world do I look like George
Clooney Brad Pitt
definitely George I am French of many
many people now and we look forward to
going to that City where the next
meetings gonna be and we will look
forward to go to a restaurant and have a
nice time and then and at the end I
realized that I was just like everybody
else I wasn't changing as I had been
asked for my oldest to change and now it
is too late to stop the melting of the
ice the idea is to change the people and
I failed
in my work so I decided that I will quit
that job I was going home to Nuuk where
my mother lives
[Music]
welcome home my mother was sitting on my
father's chair
we took our hands together she closed
her eyes she said son you're just gonna
have to learn to melt the ice in the
heart of man only by melting the ice in
the heart of man the man will have a
chance to change and I can still hear
her saying that I did not succeed
because I failed to change the
leadership of the world we still talk
about the same old stuff for the last 40
years they've been trying to get to an
agreement
[Music]
no matter what we do we cannot stop the
normally because we cannot but
politically the research talk about it
because it's just too overwhelming and
people we will scare the people I rather
scare the people and wake them up and
let them down in ignorance
[Music]
by IceBridge
go forth and science IceBridge the slice
of time that we live in our earth looks
like this because of how big the ice
sheets are if they weren't there our
planet would look entirely different
because all that water it would be in
the ocean just keep that in mind that as
they start to change our planet as a
whole will start to change so
[Music]
there's really only one place for that
ice to go it has to go into the oceans
and raise sea level and that's support
not only for the United States who
understand what's going to happen to our
coastal cities but also for our places
around the world because so much of the
human population around the world lives
very close to sea level public policy
decisions will have to be made to shore
up all that infrastructure and those
public policy decisions need to be
informed by facts not by politics but by
facts
[Music]
[Applause]
the only thing we can do now is to
become the hope for the world in which
we live you personally can become the
hope in the world you live in
so my prayer is that one of you will
awaken in the spirit and become the
guiding light for the people in the
world to the world in which we live
needs hope that the greatest need
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]